welcome to this video playing Grand
Master Tyler trail for trial from
Slovenia I'm Marco Tata okay let's see
what opening we get I think he's usually
playing the bogo what I'm not mistaken
maybe try try something else the Tauri
attacker not that I mind playing against
the bogo but let's let's go for some
variety okay yeah b6 normal response
just developing here
an ambitious way to play as sg5 is not
going for it though g5 and tonight h5
but okay I haven't canceled yet this is
important because of what i'm trying to
do next I'm trying to trying to attack
here can I cannot play h 4G 4G 5 let's
try edge for me let's see what is what
is doing maybe g6 here he could play you
five though of course going forward
instant come out to play still let's
let's try that I see maybe you can suck
on de for EDC d90 for this is may be
possible okay okay then g5 I thought ed
CD 94 was good i think ed row create
very dangerous as i saw everyone looks
at looks good for white I think okay
let's see can take here
interesting
okay I need to take it you take d3 I
guess and do I have something else here
i know i need i need to take and now if
I castle long what is he going to do
maybe Bishop Bishop very rude to f5 ok
so let's heart to to play without the
rook so long castle and then an
important idea is Knight to g5 yeah he
played as expected
I wonder about about the movie form a
floor maybe I need to do something like
that the the bishop is really strong at
five
yeah okay let's do that Bishop f5 I have
Queen a form this is a good square okay
I cannot play rupee area and this is a
good square root g 1 94 on those ideas
this is a bit a bit unlucky this
configuration for him knight on f6 and
the bishop
there are some technical ideas oaktree
one this is a mysterious yeah c7 was
saying but I'm never going to take that
okay whoops whoop jawani with the idea
94 others also d5 d5 and 94 could could
be really really dangerous for him the
others is actually a more than
dangerously don't see a defense to be
honest looks looks very very tricky fine
how are you going to get out of this
cannot move the bishop yeah something
like that yeah this is actually a good
move okay but how how do i improve that
it looks it looks they're very dangerous
for for Black Knight f3 on
night c4 night sea foam is also
interesting intending 95 and attending
93 d6 is also an idea yeah there's some
pressure complicated very complicated
position maybe abid I thought maybe you
should move the better but it wouldn't
it wouldn't is this position okay let's
let's play it simple right back so that
it probably has to play Bishop d7 after
which I can I can exchange
interesting why so there's some other
move I don't really see another move
okay to age seven okay so if i take he's
intending to play he's intending to play
after c4 is he wants to place his six I
see
yeah okay I have no no big choice
I've got a good structure but this is
still a pretty good piece on age seven
hard too hard to play I'm probably
better but not not easy it could also be
a could also be the blackest okay yeah
let's get out of the sea foam
let's go to the south yeah the stubble
porn basically means that i'm playing
with an extra porn i'm on the queenside
it's still not easy we are wants to
activate the rukon g6 okay let's block
that
time warning now don't f I don't have
enough time to he's got our form who
came so I'm still hoping that um better
King position will will will help yeah
yeah taking on g6 wasn't ideal but I
didn't really see what else to do the
limited time check check check check and
the draw my own game Kieran I only had
five seconds so I'm glad to to drawing
maybe maybe I should win yeah but i
didn't i didn't have any time I it's
actually really easy I can just stay put
here just just just a couple of seconds
at UCM yeah i can i can do promise I
kicking about it can never win the night
once he goes there I can push pawns and
it's very easy yeah maybe I would have
managed this with this time though even
though um
yeah it was a bit unlucky that I'm not
unlucky i mean i didn't really
appreciate that I that does F form yeah
i'm a bit better with the king and this
this is in effect an extra porn maybe I
should just push here and rook maybe b5
hard to say if I can give up the the
pawn here like that
and hard to say are the same very
difficult but let's say check let's
check quickly the opening if I'm right I
think you missed a very good move here I
think ed CD 94 m yeah and black is
winning yeah I said that during the game
this is how I saw this too late this is
the lady m and then if I put something
here this is d 5 or maybe maybe even
taking oops then d 5 and black is
winning so this wasn't a good idea just
mistimed like I could try that but
should castle first even that is a bit
shaky but maybe this is what I should
have done okay thanks for watching